(audience applauding)
- I'm Carson Daly, you're
host for the next few minutes.
Here with me, The Voice coaches,
the great Gwen Stefani.
- What.
- John Legend, Blake Shelton,
and of course, Kelly Clarkson!
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- Also joining us in his
booth backstage is comedian
and celebrity voice impersonator
Josh Robert Thompson.
Hi, Josh!
- Hello.
(audience applauding)
- It is time to play
guess the famous voice,
famous Voice coaches.
♪ Guess that famous voice ♪
♪ Famous Voice coaches ♪
All right, the game is very simple.
We've got two teams, boys versus girls.
Kelly and Gwen,
they're going to be playing
for all the ladies in the audience.
Blake and John,
they'll be playing for all
the men in the audience
and we're sending the winning team home
with a new Yamaha YAS-109 Sound bar.
- [Kelly] Ooh!
(audience cheering)
- Josh is going to do
a celebrity impression,
if the coaches think they
know the voice he's doing,
they'll just hit their button.
They are allowed to ask the
famous voice one question,
so you can ask the famous
voice a question, all right?
- Then you've got to guess--
- This sounds like the premise
of another show on...
- [Carson] Who it is.
- [Kelly] No, I don't know
what you're referring to.
I don't know what you're referring to.
- [Blake] For God's sake, can we play?
- If you're right, you get a point,
if you're wrong, the other team
can ask a question and steal, alright?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'm gonna let Kelly win.
- No, you play first!
- Josh let's start this sucker off--
- [Blake] You're on the same team.
- Here we go.
Josh, who is our first famous voice?
- Well let me tell you
something, first of all,
of all the morning talk shows--
(button dings)
- He's a body builder!
- No, it didn't light up.
- Wait.
- It didn't light up
or anything.
- [Carson] That's all
right, it's her show.
- No, it's Arnold Schwarzenegger!
- That is correct!
- Yeah!
- Hooray!
(audience cheering)
- I thought they were gonna sing.
- I thought they were going to sing too.
- It's one to nothing.
- [Kelly] No!
- [John] I thought they
were going to sing.
- And this pice of crap show,
this doesn't even light up!
- It's the first season!
(audience laughing)
- [Carson] Season two, they'll get one
that's connected to something.
- Season two!
(speech drowned out by yelling)
- We got picked up, next
season it'll light up!
- All right guys.
(audience cheering)
Score, one to nothing.
Let's get to it.
Who's our next famous voice?
- Come on Kelly!
- Hey man, I'm just sitting
back here with my shirt off,
playing some bongos--
(button dings)
- I know it!
He's in Austin!
Did you got to school in Austin?
Did you got to college?
- I sure did and I'm smoking
something I can't mention.
- Matthew McConaughey!
- That's correct!
(audience cheering)
Kelly Clarkson!
Two points for the ladies.
(audience cheering)
- Wow, it's really interesting
how the host of the show keeps getting
all the answers right.
- I didn't know!
- That is true, that is true.
- No, no!
- That's really interesting
that the host of the show--
- I do not cheat!
- Keeps getting the answers right.
- They did not tell me.
I am just awesome.
- How convenient is that?
- I am just awesome.
- I'm just awesome!
They did not tell me!
- All right, the score
is two to nothing, girls.
A bit of a button hog
over here, but here we go.
Who's our next famous voice?
- Now listen boys, I wanna let you know
that I was the sexiest--
(button dings)
- Oh, oh I know that.
- John Legend.
- Morgan Freeman.
- Yeah!
- That is correct, the
boys are on the board.
- How do you do that?
- I knew that one, damn it.
- Yes!
- Two to one.
- Two against one.
- Good voices.
- Morgan Freeman, that was amazing.
- He's really good.
- Gosh, I am not good at this.
- I appreciate that.
I will narrate you for a fee.
- That's alright, I got you boo.
- Morgan, what did you do,
what did you do after
you got out of Shawshank?
- After, I got out of Shawshank,
I got bought me some penguins.
- Oh.
- Oh my gosh!
You're unreal!
- He's really good.
- Yeah, and I just followed
them around and I narrated them.
That's what I do.
- [Carson] That's right, you did.
- I know that's right,
I know that's right.
- Oh my gosh.
- That's uncanny.
- Josh, who's next?
- Hey, look guys, y'all
know I'm a rapper man.
I'm a rapper, okay, that's what I do
and now don't make me bring
back the mullet, okay?
(button dings)
I'm not playing around guys.
- Hey, hey ,hey!
- Oh, that's Blake Shelton!
- No, no, no!
We did not say that!
- Yes.
- [Josh] I'll do it, I'll
bring back the mullet.
I'll do it.
- It's Blake.
- Wait, I thought that that
was, wait, team discussion.
- Deliberate and I need your final answer.
- Wait, let's ask one question?
- Okay.
- Do you have--
- Bill Ray Cyrus.
- No, that's mine.
You don't.
Do you have a daughter in music?
- Do I?
- Yeah, do you have a daughter
that's really popular in music?
- No, no, I don't, no, I don't.
- Oh, you were right.
You were right, go.
- Gwen, you wanna answer this?
- Do you have a girlfriend on The Voice?
- That's super hot?
- You know I do.
- Woo, I won!
(audience cheering)
I got one!
- Blake Shelton is the correct answer
as guessed by Gwen Stefani.
(audience applauding)
- I thought it was Billy Ray Cyrus.
- Don't even know your own voice, man.
- That was good.
- I totally thought it
was Billy Ray Cyrus.
- Seriously, I'm so excited
for myself that I got one.
- Can you see how competitive I am?
I was like that's not our answer!
- I know!
She goes, team meeting!
(laughing)
- Because I thought it
was Billy Ray Cyrus.
You were right.
- Josh, do you call restaurants
and get good seating
because you're Blake Shelton?
- Sure man, yeah.
No, I get all the best seating, yeah.
- He does not sound like Blake.
- He sounds like Billy Ray Cyrus.
- I don't buy it.
- [Josh] I was doing my
Morgan Freeman again.
I started doing Morgan Freeman.
- [Carson] Yeah, That's
was like Blake Freeman.
- That's Blake Freeman.
- Because he said the mullet
thing, that's when I knew.
- That's why I thought Billy Ray Cyrus.
- Oh, good point.
- How many country artists
used to have a mullet though?
Probably a lot.
- But he threatens to
bring it back all the time.
- I will pay you can
ungodly amount of money
to bring the mullet back. (laughing)
- You will?
- Not that you need it.
- Yes, exactly.
- Can you put that on tape?
- He's gon' do it.
- Okay, we have--
- All right, we have time for one more.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Final voice, this
one is worth 20 points.
Josh?
- It's like Family Feud.
The last one.
- I see you.
Are you talking to me?
(button dings)
- Oh!
- I'm looking at you.
- Kelly hits the button.
- I mean were you in a movie called,
"Falling in Love with Meryl Streep"?
- Wow.
- That's a deep cut, that is a deep cut.
- Okay, were you in "Meet the Fockers"?
- [Josh] Yes, I was.
- Robert De Niro!
(audience cheering)
- [Carson] That is correct.
(yelling)
Robert De Niro.
- He didn't really sound like him.
- Yes!
- Oh my god!
- [Kelly] I love games!
- Oh look, he's so cute.
- Robert De Niro, the
girls are the winners!
- [Kelly] I love games!
- The ladies win!
- I didn't know the answers.
- [Blake] Is that cheating a little bit?
- Okay.
- [John] I am pretty
sure, I'm pretty sure.
- Okay, but because I am nuts--
- [Blake] A little bit cheating.
- We did not cheat!
They did not tell me.
I would never cheat.
- You played very aggressively.
- Can I ask you a question?
- Go.
- When you do this show, do y'all go over,
what's gonna happen during the show?
- In the briefing.
- Producing.
- [Blake] Exactly.
- No, no, no sir.
- You cheat!
- In the briefing, which this
is actually the only show
I did not have a briefing
for, but in the briefing,
it didn't say anything.
It just said they'll ask a question here
and then the answer--
- [Crew Member] She had a special script.
- I had a special script!
- You had a special script.
- A special script with answers!
- No, with nothing in it.
- Oh, a special script.
- And the answer is,
Robert de Niro.
- I am just awesome!
- Wait, but because this is
my show, everyone's a winner
so you're all going home with
the Yamaha YAS-109 Sound Bar.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, I take it back, I take it back!
- It's the best way to
immerse yourself in the music
and sounds you love from
all your favorite shows,
movies and artists.
- Thank you, thank you!
Plus, this Yamaha Sound
Bar is packed with features
including built-in subwoofers,
Alexa voice control,
music streaming services,
and 3D surround sound.
This is awesome!
(audience cheering)